(intense music)
(bass drum pounds)
(record scratches)
- Are we rolling?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Why is it breaking the internet?
It's just Ramen.
- [Blue Hair] We're getting ready
to taste Kylie Jenner's Ramen recipe.
She Snapchatted it recently
to all of her fans.
- Us. (laughs)
- [Right] Us, the two of us.
- I think Kylie is the
voice of the new generation.
- I'm aware of what's going on with them.
I keep up with them, but
I don't watch the show.
I just know.
- It's not that I really
hate the Kardashians;
it's that I'm completely confused by them.
"You won't believe what
Kylie puts in her Ramen."
I look at it, I'm like this
is what all my Asian friends
have been doing for forever.
- I don't know a damn
thing about the Ramen
that Kylie makes.
I know about the Ramen that I make.
I throw sour cream in
there, tapatio, and lime.
- I don't really fuck with Ramen.
- Literally it was just
a picture, and she said,
"I add garlic, and egg,
and butter to my Ramen."
Doesn't tell us how much.
Doesn't tell us like why.
(laughs)
Doesn't show us how to do
it, and we're all doing it.
Bow down to Kylie, who has
a lot of power. (laughs)
(bell dings)
- (laughs) If I come to your house and you
severed me this shit, I'd be like,
"Girl, what the hell?"
- It looks like something you would get
at the best Chinese takeout store.
- This looks like something
my dog coughed up.
(slurps)
- Oh my god.
- [Right] Oh my god.
- Actually.
- It's actually really good.
- [Man] Yeah. (laughs)
- Could you just give me like
five minutes to finish this?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Kinda tastes like popcorn
a bit because of the butter.
- It's a good base.
It could've added more stuff.
- [Man] Yeah.
- The garlic powder is
doing a lot of work.
- That is really salty.
- Well that's the sodium
packet in the Ramen.
- Do you think she adds seasoning in it?
- She's using that packet,
I know that packet.
(bell dings)
I live that life, I know that packet.
- It's the perfect amount of garlic.
Then again, we don't know
how much she puts in it,
so maybe we're the geniuses.
- She just finished her bowl.
Look at this, look at this America.
- It's real good.
- Just ate all of this. (laughs)
- I don't understand why
people have not put stuff
in their Ramen before.
- Do people not put stuff in their Ramen?
That's why people are making a big deal.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Oh my god, that's so sad.
- I feel like at this point though,
she could literally just throw
anything together into a bowl
and it would go viral.
- And it would sell.
Ramen prices are gonna go up now.
- Are people buying more Ramen?
- Are they?
She should get research on that.
(bell dings)
- We need to use Kylie for more things,
to get more food out there.
- There's a bunch of rich
teenagers in Calabasas
eating Ramen Noodles.
- The Kardashian-Jenner kids
found it, and we're like,
"What is this incredibly
exotic Japanese food?" (laughs)
- This is like the most
relatable thing about her so far,
the fact that she eats
Ramen, and so do we.
That's it, that's all we have in common.
- Who knew she would
be the one that's like
gonna become the next Kim, you know?
No one saw it coming.
- I saw it coming.